c'est sur les bords du fleuve ob et
qu'était la résidence du général de
gaulle une ville a enfoui dans le dense
frayage de la région c'est de là que
martin au président de la république ce
matin vers la cité des savants où
l'attendaient les journalistes escorté
de deux motards en chemise de percale
grise
la voiture présidentielle était
certainement la plus imposante qu'on ait
vu ici dans le coin depuis longtemps les
fanions des slogans souhaitait la
bienvenue au président de la république
française avec une ici par milk and have
rencker président de la section
sibérienne de l'académie des sciences
la capitale de la science sibérienne
aînés tout à fait récemment en 57
il ya quelques années on avait décidé
d'y créer un important centre
scientifique de moscou le premier groupe
de savants ces deux installés non loin
de domo simiesque lors du lease back de
rondins bâti en pleine taïga
après avoir écouté les explications le
président de la république française de
répondre ainsi la réputation date l
académie ghorab
a largement dépassé nos frontières et
cela non pas seulement à cause la grande
importance de la grande qualité des
travaux qu'ils accomplissent qu'en
raison de la haute idée qui a présidé à
sa création
il s'agit là de la conjonction indigne
de l'esprit moderne et de la tradition
comment pourrait-on oublier en effet que
la grande académie des sciences qui me
reçoit à l'académie corrode continue
celle que pierre le grand en 1725 fonda
dans la capitale qu'ils bâtissent est
alors au contact de l'occident par la
suite le même souffle qui animait nar
pierre et qui caractérise votre preuve
vous apportez vers la sibérie pour y
découvrir d'énormes richesses pétrole
case métaux et caetera et pour y
construire des cités nouvelles et
notamment par une décision
impressionnante
bravant le froid et la distance cette
sorte du capital de la science société
académique world est une oeuvre
universelle comme l'est la science
elle-même qui peut douter en effet que
le sort de l'ensemble des hommes et
celui de chacun d'entre eux dépendent de
ce qui est accompli ici et ailleurs pour
conquérir cet immense domaine un penseur
français
teilhard de chardin évoquait justement
une terre où les télescopes géants et
les broyeurs d'atomes
absorberont plus d'or et attireront plus
d'admiration que les bombes et canon une
terre non seulement l'armée
groupe b et subventionner des chercheurs
les encore l'homme de la rue considérera
que le problème du jour
c'est un secret et un pouvoir de plus
arraché au corpus qu aux astres à la
matière organiser une terre enfin où
c'est pour savoir plus nous que pour
avoir qu'on donnera sa vie la france
vous le savez s'applique elle aussi à
cette tâche capitale comme elle l'a fait
de tout temps elles aident ceux qui s'y
consacre
et ceux qui cherchent à pénétrer les
structures de l'univers de la matière et
de la vie aussi considère-t-elle academ
gorod non seulement avec intérêt mais
avec admiration et elle n'en souhaite
que plus ardemment de voir ces
mathématiciens et physiciens c'est
chimistes et biologistes ces
anthropologues ces économistes ces
philosophes collaborer avec les vôtres
puisse donc la science soviétique et la
science française unie pour le progrès
et hommes tandis que la russie et la
france
si nietzsche pour la paix du monde
le président de la république devait
ensuite visiter quelques-uns des 16
instituts de la cité des savants ainsi
le cortège circulant à travers les
différents bâtiments de cet ensemble
scientifique véritablement
impressionnant parler fort à la fois
cohérent et originale dont il témoigne
voici le président de la république vite
un cyclotron où ils écoutent ce avec
beaucoup d'attention les explications
scientifiques qui lui sont fournis par
les dirigeants
d'acadie bolt
voici encore d'autres bâtiments sainteny
les très étendue elle est dispersée à
travers la taïga sibérienne dans de
vrais nombreux bâtiments dont voici le
personnel chercheurs et personnels
auxiliaires
le général de vos loyers francs un
contact direct sous le regard
approbateur
monsieur x de leur lit président du
soviet suprême qui l'accompagnent depuis
moscou au cours de ce voyage en sibérie
et ce matin le général de gaulle à
retrouver encore des sibériens venus lui
souhaiter
au revoir lorsqu'il est reparti de la
voix si bien que lorsqu'il s'est dirigé
vers l'aéroport de novossibirsk aéroport
d'où il a gagné un lieu en principe
secret qui est le cosmodrome de
baïkonour vous le voyez cette nouvelle
journée de samedi est également placée
sous le signe de la science et même de
la science la plus avancée puisqu'il
s'agit de la science spatiale donc le
général de gaulle a fait un voyage de
quatre heures en tout de vie depuis
novossibirsk eu trois heures d'avion et
une heure de train ou se rendre sur ce
choix soit drôme d'où partent les
spoutniks les satellites les vaisseau
cosmique souliers visite sans précédent
nous vous l'avons déjà dit puisque
jamais une personnalité occidentale elle
avait été admise à visiter at-elle
cosmodrome soviétique dont les effets
sont fait jour extrêmement bien gardé
dépendra de vous dire d'ailleurs que la
délégation française à méditer réduit
vraiment au minimum puisque avec le
président de la république il n'y avait
que trois personnes l'une de ces trois
personnes et un monsieur comme de
mirville ministre des affaires
étrangères maintenant qu'est ce que le
président de la république a vu à
baïkonour alors là on est un petit peu
réduit aux hypothèses car autour de
cette ville je voulais dit monsieur créé
reste bien gardé
l'agent se tasse à publier un tout petit
dépêche de trois lignes mentionnant
l'événement sans plus toutefois j'ai
noté que cette même agence tu as annoncé
un peu plus tard la mise sur orbite d'un
123 iem satellite de la série cosmos
alors je me demande si ce cosmos 122
n'est pas une sorte de feu d'artifice
tiré en quelque sorte à l'honneur
en français quoi qu'il en soit après
avoir visité le cosmodrome le général de
gaulle a repris l'avion est dans une
grande diagonale comprend l'urss
il est en train de gagner leningrad où
il doit être d'ailleurs en train
d'atterrir à l'heure où je vous parle
leningrad une fusion d'un public va être
fameuses zones blanches de juin est
aussi un programme officiel dans filière
m'en charge